[Music]
disclaimer
this video highlights the not so
favorable aspects of integrating vision
and language
for information on risk and side effects
please read your favorite publication
and ask your machine learning researcher
or
engineer hey there
did you watch miss coffee beans previous
video if not
check it out right now and then come
back to this video
last time she told us about the symptoms
that are a clear hint that something
fishy is going on when integrating
vision and language with
deep learning methods it seems that
one modality is usually almost forgotten
even though the tasks are defined to
require the understanding of
both modalities to deliver the right
answer
in this video miss coffeebean is going
to tell us what she found
further on her journey through the dark
paper forest
miss coffee bean what are the reasons
for problems in vision and language
fusion
on my journey i encountered two sources
of all
evil some say the source of problems
when integrating vision and language
is in the data while others say it is in
the neural network based models
let's start with the accusations against
the data
the vqa data set was released in 2015
and a lot of work was invested by
researchers to get on top of the
challenge leaderboard
then 2017 a version 2 of the vqa dataset
had to be released
since obvious biases in the data were
detected
these biases were making the undesired
happen
the model could focus only on the text
ignoring the image
it's in the title making the v in vqa
matter for example far too numerous
how many questions have the answer to
if the question is about sport then
usually the correct answer is tennis
also questions like is there a special
something in the image
bear the answer yes since humans
contributing for the data set collection
usually do not ask if there is a horse
in the image if there is none to be seen
how would they even get the idea of a
horse in the first place
so these obvious biases were removed but
there are suspicions that neural
networks can also rely on not so obvious
biases and many models still seem to
ignore the image far too much
what holds for vqa usually holds for
visual dialogue too
as visual dialogue is simply put vqa
with history
this paper shows a very simple
statistical method
not even neural networks without
accessing the image
or the sequence of the dialogue and this
method performs on par
on some metrics with extremely complex
neural models
of course authors of the original visual
dialogue papers
did not take the critique well if you
want to read how researchers fight
check the links to these papers and the
response in the description below
but whatever side you are on i think
that one must take this alarm seriously
it is always tricky to produce clean
training data because the fingerprints
of the data collectors are everywhere
on it and neural networks are extremely
good at exploiting every hint and bias
to get to the right answer
even if for the wrong reasons but
apart from neural networks exploiting
bias in the data
it seems to be something fundamentally
wrong with neural networks trying to
fuse modalities
so it is time for us to discuss the
problems that models might inherently
have we think this question is still
very very poorly investigated
but we have one research product to show
you
this paper conducts a very simple yet
fundamental
experiment given an image that can be
described by only one word
a neural network has to construct a word
that is describing
the image not the classification task
where the network has to choose the
right index of the right class to which
we humans have assigned the labels it is
rather
a regression task where the model has to
come up with the right
word embedding that best fits to the
picture
simply put they try to translate images
to single words rather than a whole
sentence like in image captioning
what do we expect it should be an easy
task right
image captioning is a much harder task
and
neural networks can do it so why should
it not be possible to translate an image
to a single
word and you're right it is possible
the neural network performs with an
impressive accuracy
only that the paper looks a little bit
closer
it also measures how far the neural
network can transform
the input space to make it look like the
output space
and here the results are surprising it
turns out that the neural network is
really bad at that
it stays much closer to the input
modality
which is the image even though the
network is trained to fully transform
the image space to the textual
word embedding space it preserves the
neighborhoods of the input space
rather than construct the output space
why
because neural nets are guaranteeing
continuity and preserved topology
we think that there is still very much
to investigate along this line
especially the case when both visual and
textual modalities are mapped by neural
network into a common space
because this was only a special case
where the image only was transformed
but even this special case analysis is a
strong alarm signal when talking about
neural networks in multimodal
research as they are universal
approximators given infinite training
time and data we expect them to be the
solution to all
our multimodal problems but perhaps we
expect too much from them in our real
setting with not so much training data
or training time
like in the example seen before the
neural network was able to transform
single data points from the image to the
textual modality but
was not able to sensibly transform the
space in between
with infinitely many training samples
this would not have been a problem
since the network would have had a
training sample for every
point in the space but even if we would
have these
infinite resources we have seen how
problematic
data and biases can be when integrating
vision and language
and that we can insert multi-modal
fusion difficulties when choosing a
model
or architecture we could end our video
here
since this is what's miss coffee bean
found on her search for hints and
reasons
on why current vision and language
models fail
where they fail but we want to spend a
minute on multimodal models that are
coming out right now
beating the previous state of the art
but have not been yet more thoroughly
investigated for problems
yes we are talking about the multi-modal
transformers which
are all variations of the same theme of
processing
images and text and combining them with
transformer modules
and cross-modal attention for more
details on how this architecture works
check out our previous video on wilbert
link below
multimodal transformers show through
their better accuracy on multi-modal
tasks and
attention visualization that they are
better at combining the visual and
textual modalities
but still a recent publication suggests
that for multimodal transformers
it seems again that quote
the textual modality plays a more
important role than
image in making final decisions
so here we are again at the same problem
that existed even before multiple
transformers
the inequality of modalities and the
curse of biased data sets towards the
textual modality
so what do we do now more research
the relevant papers for this video are
in the description below
if you are interested to investigate the
root of the problem yourself
this video is of course not an
exhaustive literature
enumeration of all problems in
multimodal integration
it's rather just a hint of where to look
when searching for
trouble i mean in an academic sense
anyway what do you think let us know in
the comments
what your thoughts and observations are
see you next time okay bye
[Music]
[Music]
you